[Music]
in bad-joke news submitted by Winx stuff
Oh remember that baby sad song yeah Winx
stuff an NYPD commander is being
investigated for threatening rapper 50
Cent's life really oh we were just
talking about maybe that's why they said
Winx yeah 50 cent stayed around for a
while yeah when precinct commander is
being investigated by the NYPD for
allegedly threatening 50 Cent's life
because at a roll call this deputy
inspector named Immanuel Gonzalez he
pretty much told everyone at the roll
call to shoot him on sight today 50 cent
so they were saying that the design was
gonna be at this boxing match and yeah
that's when he said that why say stuff
like that right yeah there's a little
bit of a backstory to that you can't
shoot anyone well a month before that
roll call
what's like where did the roll call
happen I don't think I'm briefing at the
police oh like it's like in the morning
all the cops get together and in the
[ __ ] Commissioner gets in the front
end and he's like alright today we're
looking for the for the something killer
or whatever we're gonna run him down
those Liam jail okay so use that
commanding officer so that means a cop
looking ratted him out he's like oh I
can't believe you said that she'll tell
50 fine yeah okay 57 was expected to
attend an NYPD sanctioned boxing match
in the Bronx so that's what like the
whole briefing was about right and so
that's when Manuel Gonzales told the
officers to shoot him on sight
so a lot before that as a joke was a
joke it's a good defense come on site
yeah so he's had this like ongoing beef
with 50 like a real beef or it's
one-sided like he just doesn't like them
okay so let me tell you what the beef is
with City or with Curtis with Curtis
Jackson so a month before the roll call
g5 gonzales filed
and aggravated harassment complaint
claiming that 50-cent threatened him on
Instagram and so the thing that was
happening here is that 50-cent posted
post it up something about this park I'm
sorry this club called love and lust
which is one a 50 Cent's favorite places
to go and so he ended up writing in the
caption get the strap which is slang for
get a gun but that's also his like
catchphrase right now too so I don't I
don't know to promote his new drink or I
forgot what it was but he's still doing
it and almost everything yeah so this
thing about love and lust was the fact
that Gonzales is accused of shaking down
the owner of love and lust and pretty
much demanding 11 free round round-trip
ticket to Puerto Rico tickets and a
generator for a doctor after Hurricane
Maria hit Puerto Rico so that's what
Gonzales was trying to get from the
owner of love and lust and so when the
owner said like no or whatever he
refused it we're a respectable strip
club buddy
that's when um the precinct hammered
down on the club with violations and as
a result of that love and lust lost its
liquor license and one shut down no
that's when you know 50 cent heard about
this and you posted up about it with the
caption of that and then that's what led
to the death threat at the roll call
there are in justices coming from
justice I'm so shocked
I remember watching movies and it
happens in the movies all the time where
the bad guys the cops and they've been
extorting businesses and it takes a good
gangsta to expose all of that look good
gangster a good gangster
sometimes money's based on real-life
[ __ ] like rampart like it doesn't happen
in real why does teeth ever
is alive Gonzalez he hasn't yeah his
teeth his teeth are bright the stars are
much brighter whereas 50 Cent's are much
brighter than the stars yeah it's it's
brighter than his [ __ ] neck peace
it's better than the light dude yeah it
is the lights yellow needs a [ __ ]
white meat yup the white needs needs a
ton Jonah that guy's an idiot he didn't
think you would get I guess they
wouldn't have a they think they run this
year is the cop gonna be punished never
they didn't ever Sox well I mean that's
what they're saying that NYPD is
investigating I wonder how often they
extort places all the time probably a
part of me is like I don't know if I'm
fully against the what's nunca guardo
hmm
Gonzalez's good Zaza side because it's
also just like locker room talk you know
so if you're at your roll call and then
you're typing everybody up alright get
these [ __ ] well but no oh you
called the criminal [ __ ] mmm-hmm
you know there's just like you just have
locker room talk so I don't know if like
shooting him on sight is really you have
to kind of take in to context - okay
okay do the dude do it for me dude
deliver the the like if I'll ask Eduardo
guardo good morning ladies and gentlemen
good morning ladies and umin uh as you
guys know my ongoing beef with 50 cent
and still ongoing I [ __ ] hate this
[ __ ] to us hyper sense we shut
down that [ __ ] Club love and less
been coming after me this guy is gonna
be at this boxing match okay
[ __ ] we're gonna try to pin
anything we can on this [ __ ]
if that fails we're gonna shoot them on
sight
alright see you guys
[Music]
well I'm a bad quarter with the
backstory makes it not a joke right the
back story makes it on a joke because of
the love and lust thing and makes it not
that fun yeah and I forgot to mention
so when 50 cent posted that up on his
Instagram then he said that he got a
whole bunch of his own threats against
him including [ __ ] this commander and
blast this fool and and then that ended
up leaving him in fear of [ __ ] his
commanders not a threat dude then that's
when he ended up filing a complaint in
the department against 50 yeah of
harassment it's still not the thing that
I want to be hearing from the commander
yeah sure yeah shoot him on sight like
Oh what if he was like this he was like
we have a special celebrity that's gonna
be showing up at our boxing [ __ ] gig
right it's actually a rapper named 50
cent bring your camera yeah and he's
wanted cities and he's wanted if you
he's wanted dead or alive this reminds
me of a bit that Ronald Reagan did after
he got elected president he was doing
bits he did a bit yeah he did a lot of
bits so he so he everyone was saying in
the run-up to his election or whatever
that he was like crazy he's gonna blow
up the whole world or some [ __ ] Wow so I
don't know there was like an ad done at
the time where it's like Reagan's gonna
[ __ ] blow up like who use nukes and
blow up the world of some [ __ ] right
that's like what you do in politics you
try to pin your another guy's crazy well
[ __ ] okay so Reagan gets elected and
then he does in a speech he's like he's
like the bombing starts in five minutes
and he's just doing it and it got a
laugh but then a lot of people and the
media and [ __ ] we're all like [ __ ]
pissed cause like United States I knew
that could have been construed and
misconstrued ISM in context looking back
that's like wow that is very mild yeah
but I think it's interesting because of
because this is the police chief because
he has that history it does make it
weird didn't go more against intent for
it in a good way I am Bobby I'm looking
for any angle to be for him
oh wait wait till Shane Dawson makes a
documentary about the NYPD extorting
businesses true I always want to try to
do the camera
argument and just to play but this one's
a tough it's a tough one it sorry to
justify being the commander of police
force and being like yes shoot that guy
on sight
walks away that's an actual command that
can go down yeah cuz then what if what
if someone like was like okay and it's
like oh I was just kidding with you yeah
what if there was an ass burger
policeman that took everything literally
and he was like that's what the captain
said
yeah and he shot him and then you'd be
liable cuz yeah yeah I told you to shoot
him right so so then you go back to that
where it's like it's Reagan he is the
president he does say the bombing
started five minutes on this thing what
so the guy with guy with the buns like
right right maybe not one guy one guy
should not with that guy he's like I'm
ready to do my job get the notice it
he's like well [ __ ] why didn't anybody
tell me yeah okay I hope the president's
the one that's supposed to press the
button in the movie good point but
there's a guy with a suit like that it
takes it to yeah yeah and they go all
right it's time or their keys yeah the
key to keep vice president to one not be
the same place the same time or some
[ __ ] during moments of threat oh not
when they're threatening other people
now we're about the Boswell's
I don't know I don't know [ __ ] about
that president stuff no I just made it
up cuz from the movies yeah I knew that
[ __ ] I do want to go on Air Force One if
they ever have a tour I think has to be
a like a while before they do it cuz
like in the moment it's like all they've
got all those like secrets you know it's
go check out an old one yeah yeah you
know what's crazy about being a
president is like while you are actually
in office [ __ ] people hate your ass
right the minute the day after you leave
you're just like some dude it's [ __ ]
insane just our uncle uncle George
one hated that what do presidents do
after like this myself they write books
they [ __ ] do dinners looks like they
speak at graduations and [ __ ] they don't
nothing they get that salary the three
hundred four hundred five hundred
thousand dollar salary for the rest of
their life oh yeah they make way [ __ ]
more when they leave what the horseshit
were they building security feeling I
love the horseshit where they build a
monument to themselves aka Presidential
Library where they just jerk off in
every room all over their own presidency
I mean wouldn't you I know you wouldn't
[ __ ] no I think that shit's wrong as
[ __ ] oh yeah they spent billions of
dollars on their own [ __ ] I would
celebrate my [ __ ] my people are gonna
remember me till the day till forever
[Music]